the severe weather that is pounding the
south at least two tornadoes including
this one tore through new orleans and
the surrounding area at least one person
was killed and many more were injured
the town of araby that's just east of
new orleans was hit especially hard the
homes knocked off their foundations the
debris scattered far and wide our lead
national correspondent david bagnow is
in arabi with more on the story david i
know this is your home state how's it
looking what are you seeing
listen my friend we were driving around
assessing the damage when we rolled up
on this a school bus tossed like toys in
fact there are two on this street right
behind arabi elementary school now on
average a school bus weighs about 25 000
pounds that's how powerful that tornado
was and then watch this across the
street i said wait a minute where do
those stairs lead to right the steps
where would that go and somebody said oh
that used to be somebody's front door
you'd come here and walk in the house i
said well where's the house
they said that's it the tornado picked
it up moved it off its blocks and
literally shoved it about five yards
with the people who lived there inside
the first tornado hit the new orleans
area right after dinner time about 7 30
p.m local time
[Laughter]
dude
[Laughter]
that is what it looked like a tornado
moving through a major american city new
orleans
this is what cut through parts of new
orleans and moved into nearby saint
bernard parish
the twister moved through new orleans
lower ninth ward without doing much
damage but as it touched down in saint
bernard parish it was devastating james
dickerson was in his home in arabi
louisiana with his five-year-old son and
the house started shaking and then
when it pulled the roof off i was you
know sheltering him and then it was
pulling me off the ground his house is
now ruined
dining room here you know i had booked a
bookcase you know anyway there's the
front door was there
oh that was a church the damage in saint
bernard parish is widespread power lines
are down everywhere streets are littered
with debris that is actually pieces of
people's homes the porch of my friend's
house doesn't have a roof anymore this
tornado spawned from the same weather
system that originally started in texas
on monday and caused extensive damage
there and in oklahoma and now three
other states along the gulf coast as the
line of weather moves eastward we heard
it coming down the street
it was a lot of whistling back here
where we are in arabi louisiana you know
i'm just glad mostly everybody seems to
be accounted for i think that was a
couple of issues a block away from us
but other than that you know we're safe
look meteorologists here in the new
orleans area say surveying the damage
preliminarily it looks like the tornado
could have been an ef2 ef-3 that that
would put winds near 165 miles per hour
nothing official yet cruz will be back
out today but that's how powerful it
appears to have been
nate back to you
david thank you